good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it's Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday I have this
microphone here that makes me feel like
Christina Aguilera on the Disney family
sing-along last night and I'm not afraid
to use it hey Claude yeah she was the
only one prepared with her equipment not
her janky Little Big Town iPhone video
so we appreciate and respect a queen who
has a studio in her house much like us
yes she was prepared technologically
speaking but she did have the lyrics on
that little music stand in front of her
but you know what I'd also respect like
the fact that she wants to get it right
I also I agreed that she had her own
little music stand and she still flubbed
a few words and you know what I don't
care I don't I don't care at all we're
gonna talk about the ABC Disney family
sing-along it is a story I want to get
all of your thoughts
I watched 45 minutes of it I missed your
Little Big Town Singh I'm sorry that
they triggered you I know that that's
really difficult for you to see Little
Big Town on your television it is thank
you for respecting my boundaries and
that's really all you can ask for a
sister you know well we'll get into it
because I have a lot of thoughts I
watched so much TV last night so I was
excited I was literally up all night
thinking like what am I gonna say
because it's very stressful to watch TV
that you plan on recapping cuz like for
the most part everything I watched I was
saying I just want to enjoy and I don't
want to be writing notes and like
sometimes when I'm really feeling like
on top of my game I start writing [ __ ]
down but I was just tired last night and
I'm just like I'm falling into a slump
you know the the quarantine is a Ramona
coaster and I'm just like this week has
been one big downhill slope for me
between like everyone just annoying me
and everything being like ugly like I
just can't
okay well yesterday I filmed my day in
the life quarantine Edition patreon
video which will be up on our patreon
channel today and like I think it's
interesting I think it might be like
super depressing it made me realize that
like this is so sad like it's so sad
this video also I like kept dropping my
phone I just dropped my phone all the
time during quarantine so like the
quality of the video just gets
progressively worse because my camera is
like breaking it's so strange um but I
think it's actually good content I know
it's like me cleaning my shower I think
you got some good tips I did my manicure
and I feel
I'm actually becoming like an at-home
manicure expert so I'm gonna share with
you guys some of my tips and tricks
because I had like one or two tips and
one or two tricks I think maybe
yesterday was also a little bit of a
downer for everyone because in New York
we got our quarantined extended another
two weeks which I think we all knew I
never expected to be able on May first
to like run out and lick the subway but
something about it being so formal from
Governor Cuomo's sexy lips that made it
really depressing
no it wasn't sexy whatsoever it was
deeply depressing yes it's another two
weeks but it is another one whole month
from where we are at right now and I
never expected on May 1st that I could
be like dancing in the streets and we
would have a black party but I did think
that like things would start coming back
to normal and I am devastated by the
extra two weeks a night and I don't
agree and I'm very upset I'm devastated
as well I think that I always thought
June first would be like the breeding
ground of somewhat normalcy so we're
still on
no I thought June first oh okay but
we're still on track we're still on
track but I just um
obviously you're always hope for
something a little better than your
expectations you know you set a low bar
so that you're not disappointed yet Here
I am disappointed yeah and it's just
like that's still so far away that will
mean that we have been truly truly
quarantined for two months and like
things are getting better in New York
like the numbers are going down we are
flattening the curb so like in two weeks
why couldn't we just go get this on
Sarah al fresco I can't wait out of 50
percent at a 50% restaurant capacity
yeah no I mean if we are flattening the
curve like dr. Burks wanted us to then
we should like I guess still do what
we're doing so like I get it I'm just
annoyed like I can respect the decision
I feel like if I say I respect the
decision like I respect it I started
telling Vanessa Hudgins you know I mean
it's terrible but inevitable I can't you
guys think these are and if I mean if it
is May 15th that means we're only half
of the way through like this is actually
the worst time this is the worst time
and it feels like the worst time you
know it's very much adequate I'm feeling
so down and they don't want to
negative I know that people love this
podcast because we are just a beacon of
light so I will continue to try but just
everyone there like I'm struggling and
it's really the little things getting me
through like yesterday Passover being
over like that was a bright spot on a
cold stormy day and I had it cookies oh
and oh my god
Wow I literally like just woke up 20
minutes ago and I had a dream that the
gas in my building was back on and for a
second right now I thought that it was
real wow I'm so sorry for you too you
see the meatless Bellinis I made last
night yeah it was hard to look like I
wanted it when I had bullet is made of
real me oh I wouldn't even know the
difference it was so fabulous and your
meat is always like undercooked and
every time you make a Bellini so like
looked at on Instagram and then you tell
us it was bad in person so it's hard to
really want yours either
excuse me literally how [ __ ] dare you
I literally said one time my penne alla
vodka tasted like vodka now you're
throwing that in my face is that the
kind of sister friend and co-host you
are yeah I guess just now that I had
like my own Bellinis um I'm just not
gonna take [ __ ] from you that it's not
good enough you know I'm just I don't
understand like you're not a vegetarian
but you eat a lot like a vegetarian
because of like kosher restrictions but
in your house Jay you have kosher meat
like why wouldn't you just make nails
because because your husband bought up
and between your husband and Olivia they
bought up all the kosher meat in
Manhattan I can't get one ground beef
crumble so I had to get vegan meat well
you know what I actually I actually
liked it better because I don't have to
worry about cooking it up like properly
because it's pretty much ready you just
have to make it warm so I didn't have to
cook it in a pan before I put it in the
meat sauce I just had to heat it in the
meat in the sauce so no I just would
like to speak on one of the allegations
you just made about me and my family I
don't know if you're aware that like me
and Ben went to the grocery store to get
meat like four or five times before we
actually could get it like it's not
something like that you could just go
and get like you have to really want it
and it sounds like you don't want it no
because I have made alternate plans and
you know what I am living like a
a meatless life and I'm just like
walking the line as walk enix true for
me Joaquin Phoenix true for me and I
feel good about that you know that is
good but you should just make sure
you're getting all your iron and I don't
want to see bruises on your arm I have
I'm living a plant-based diet like I
feel really good about it
I'm glad just don't hurl accusations on
your plant-based diet that I'm somehow
eating all the kosher meat in New York
cuz that is rude I people ok but like
but you okay yeah no obviously other
people are eating kosher meat in New
York but it is very hard to come back
and you know what I have a lot of things
like on my list of things that I need
and kosher meat is like number 20 and
I'm not I'm not even past like number 3
I need Clorox wipes except a toaster
sent me a huge bottle of Clorox wipes
and has saved my quarantine that's
really generous see that's where we did
for like kosher meat was number one on
my list for like two weeks before I
actually got it when you see me like
clean my shower you'll understand why I
needed Clorox I think it might be really
painful for people to watch because I'm
like it's like as if I'm using a
toothbrush to clean my entire shower
what's wrong with your shower that it
needs to be clean so badly it's just
like soap scum you know if you leave it
just it's wet and then it's dry and it's
wet in this try and it just like gets
kind of dank in there and it's my
favorite part of the day so I want to
make sure like showering is my favorite
part of the day so I want to make sure
that it's as premium as possible in
these corn times I thought you meant
that cleaning your shower is your
favorite part of day like well you act
in fact cleaning my shower is my least
favorite chore of all the tourists that
I've toured my least favorite chore that
I used to do like just sporadically you
know in between like the major cleanings
but now I find myself doing almost every
day is just the floors like there's so
much dust so much crumbs and I think I'm
hyper aware of it just because of Theo
and I don't want him like eating dust
bunnies but also New York is so
disgusting like I live in a very clean
apartment and literally every day
there's new new just bunnies gathering
in the corners dust bunnies we have a
dust bunny infestation like our
apartment
I just New York is so dusty it's it's
very bad it's know that yeah it's
okay well I feel like without further
ado oh there was one thing I wanted to
mention because we spoke about the
Draper James contest giveaway brouhaha
yesterday and I got some clarification
from the teacher toasters and the quote
unquote giveaway was initially not
billed as a giveaway or contest it was
enter here teachers enter here to win a
Draper James dress the teachers had to
give all of their information like their
teacher ID number like very in-depth
personal stuff to win this dress and it
turns out they only had 250 dresses and
they weren't prepared for all the
teachers then they started to give away
discount code so teachers can buy
dresses and teachers are like we can't
buy these dresses so the teachers were
pissed and I understand it and so
priests say the right thing she made a
donation oh yeah they literally said in
their Instagram caption nothing about
contests or winners they literally just
said while supplies last and you assume
that a company that's like you know
backed by Reese Witherspoon like has
enough dresses to at least meet most of
the demand not three percent of the
demands less yeah so that's that on that
dresses for the teachers jft okay are
you ready to get into the fast side
story is that you need to know before
you wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast oh and yes I am I am but I
can't help you know noticing in my zoom
reflection like how beautiful and glowy
my skin is and not to brag but it has a
lot to do with one of our new sponsors
Metiria driven by the belief that high
performance skincare should and can be
non toxic skin compatible and affordable
nutrient was born their mission is to
create safe clinically effective
biocompatible products that deliver
visible results with prices ranging from
16 to 25 dollars yet efficacy levels
that match or exceed similar products
that are double triple or in some cases
18 times the price nutrient formulas
utilizes cutting-edge technology to
harness the healing powers and
ingredients found in nature
Nitori am is proudly made in the USA is
cruelty free paraben free gluten free
non-toxic fragrance free and
dermatologist tested while it may seem
safe to assume that all skin care
products would be compatible with skin
the assumption would be wrong in fact
there are hundreds of thousands of
skincare products in the market that
have unsafe pH levels utilize materials
that cause irritation and
inflammation to the skin or are known to
be toxic we believe it's impossible it's
impossible to achieve healthy nourished
skin without with formulas that are
unbalanced and incompatible and only use
ingredients that either directly benefit
the skin's health or support the
integrity and effectiveness of our
formulas so Jack and I have been blessed
enough to use a bunch of the products
from natori important quarantine what
else is there to do besides take care of
your skin so a lot of the cleansers and
the moisturizers are just making us feel
like a brand-new woman and look at my
skin in the zoom like you can't lie
about the power of deuterium no same
also in my patreon video from yesterday
you'll see I use the retinol regimen um
by natori 'm and i talked about how
fabulous it is and it's really been like
my saving grace
during quarantine so sign on get that
skin right nitiram is offering a special
promo code for toasters to receive a
free multi peptide eye cream with any
purchase of two items or more only Aetna
turian com add an eye cream to any
purchase of two items or more and use
the code toast to receive your eye cream
for no cost
that's Natori 'm na tu RI um calm the
coat is toast for your free eye cream
check it out love it that eye cream
rocks by the way totally worth it also
an eye cream in general is just
something that rocks its key its key ok
first story
Beyonce surprises Disney sing-alongs
show with when you wish upon a star
Beyonce surprised Disney fans and music
lovers everywhere Thursday evening by
popping into the entertainment
juggernauts Disney family sing-along on
ABC quote I'd like to dedicate all I'd
like to dedicate to all of the health
care workers who've been working
tirelessly to keep us healthy and safe
she explained before her rendition of
when you wish upon a star adding we
greatly appreciate you ok this was so
beautiful I turned I turned on the show
right as Beyonce was singing so I was
just feeling so blessed to have caught
this and I want to talk about the
special ok I want to talk about Beyonce
really quickly cuz you know I'm like a
newfound member of the hive and me and
Ben we're watching the Disney thing and
we were just pretty much fast-forwarding
through things that looked shitty and
then we stopped because even though
Beyonce's quality was nothing of the
sort like
really looked like she was filming it on
retrocam I didn't care she literally
like wheat me and Ben were just like
silent like we were dumbfounded at how
beautiful her voice was what a special
song you know like it just brings back
so many memories like as a kid and to
hear like Beyonce singing it flawlessly
like she was really excellent and
brought another she raised the bar you
know for everyone around her she did and
so overall like I don't know what I had
in mind for this special I think they
did a pretty good job with technology
and like making it less of like just
zoom at home you know everyone feel
films like multiple different angles and
and dance moves and almost was like
harmonizing with themselves at certain
points so I thought it was really good
except that it was made completely and
utterly for children like this was not
for like big dopes like us or like
nostalgic Millennials like this was for
parents who have children who don't know
what to do with them and just got an
hour of reprieve yesterday and I am so
thankful for them because like I I think
about those parents who are quarantined
who are quarantined home with their like
tots you know not babies and not and not
young adults they've got tots on their
hands they got multiple tots and that is
a lot of programming for a parent to
have to do 24/7 and now the parents are
the teachers yeah no I totally agree I
felt like stupid watching it was like
the little bit bouncing Mickey Mouse at
the bottom like going from word to word
he was so dumb for kids there were a few
things on there that were genuinely made
for me um one of them was being with
Tori Kelly singing colors of the way and
like so [ __ ] beautifully like that
song is like you forget about it as a
classic Disney song but it really brings
you chills and she is just like a star
like her voice is everything I really
really enjoyed that I also obviously
really enjoyed the Gaston rendition even
though like everyone was off their air
pods like we're flailing about and the
piano guy like was singing another song
mm Gaston like it was a mess but it was
fabulous I agree Gaston was pretty well
done thank God for air pods by the way
like what would everyone be doing in
these situations without air pods
everyone was wearing air pods literally
even Ryan Seacrest and it seems like
Ryan Seacrest had like a very small tea
the crew in his apart in his wherever he
was because it was legit and it should
because he was the host I just wish
there was more consistency with people's
um technology like to be honest it was
really cute but like Thomas rets
performance was like a vocal disgrace
and like I just needed everyone to have
the microphone that Christina Aguilera
had or Tori Kelly had like even Darrin
Chris's was really good but like where
was the mic ya know he was truly using
zoom that was like the first full one
that I saw and I was like oh my gosh
this is a lot I think this is this is a
lot but I want to talk about High School
Musical because we were really excited
about it like High School Musical has
just been everywhere recently because it
was a toast movie of the day the trilogy
and like Vanessa Hudgens she respects it
but it's inevitable
and they were teasing that Zac Effron
Zac Efron would participate and I said
on the show like Zac Efron will not be
getting down with the Wildcats and I was
right now here's my conspiracy theory
okay are you ready for it
Zac Efron like he is Ted Bundy he's
Philip Carlisle like he's not getting
down with the Wildcats that is no longer
in his contract they made it seem as
though he's like too remote to film a
dance video that could sync up with the
other dance videos so he sent like a
really sweet message because I didn't I
don't think he wanted to be seen as not
participating at all but I think my
conspiracy is that they like lessened
the quality on his video message to
drive home the point that he's in such a
remote location that he that is why he
couldn't participate where is he exactly
I don't know like in the woods somewhere
no I definitely agree that like he
wanted to be a very small part of it
like he wanted to make it seem like he
wasn't an [ __ ] who's I gotten too big
for his bridges in Hollywood to like
remember where he came from but he
didn't want to be a part of it with
everyone else like just you just to
emphasize that there's some sort of
separation like he's not Lucas Grabeel
you know ya know he's not an even I
would say the second most successful
person is Vanessa Hudgens from um and
he's not Vanessa Hudgens you know like
he is he's elsewhere in in the Hollywood
sphere I do want to
Chinn I don't know if you saw in the
dance medley at the end that was once
again uninspiring at a big letdown
Charlie to Melia was there okay
Charlie's Emilio was there there was a
lot of great cameos and you know what
even though like it wasn't in a
gymnasium and everyone wasn't wearing
like red and white track suits which is
like what I had envisioned in my heart I
know that can't happen I will say like I
did get some chills at certain points
now some of my favorite cameos were
obviously the D'Amelio family was kind
of random they had the high school
musical the musical the series cast
which was really perfect except Nene was
the only one who didn't have air pods
and she use headphones with a string so
I just think that that should be noted
the cast of descendants was there Doug
Cameron I saw her um we had pop and lock
and jam and brake marks the [ __ ] with
her kids so cute so cute
do you follow pop and lock and jamming
break on tick-tock
I don't but she comes up on my fur you
page she really leans into her high
school musical glory and the pop lock
and jam and break of it all so like it's
really premium quality content
interesting interesting oh and Ashley
Tisdale I feel like she just kind of
gets like I forgot about her in the high
school musical around yeah no I mean it
was just like really cringey you could
tell that all the parts were filmed
separately like they were scripted and
they were piecing together like they
weren't actually having a conversation
it was like you know Lucas Grabeel like
I agree yeah no I know and like Corbin
Bleu was like the the narrator of the
group I have something to say about
Corbin Bleu
he was looking hot yeah he looks good he
looks really good and I like that he was
like dancing around in his room with all
the High School Musical posters like
that's obviously the room where he goes
to cry also Raven Symone was there she
did not know the lyrics and she could
not be bothered okay I have a major
problem with celebrities who sign on to
do things maybe they're getting paid
maybe they're getting on and they just
like don't do the homework very similar
to like Tim McGraw and Faith Hill not
knowing any of the words to Taylor Swift
song when she brought them out to her
Stadium show in Nashville the song is
literally called Tim McGraw and neither
one of them bother to learn it and to me
like that seems like you have no respect
for like the people that you're working
with and I don't like that I agree with
that
about Faith Hill and Tim McGraw
like Raven Symone 20 years later doesn't
need to learn the words - we're all in
this together like she got the gist you
know no I agree so like why did they
have her because she's part of that
Disney legacy where was Hilary Duff who
I feel like Hilary Duff it's like not on
great terms with her Disney cohorts um
ever since like the rise and fall of the
Dizz the Hilary Duff reboot that like
got canceled and that's back and then
it's canceled and like she was pleading
she was like begging for it to be on
Lulu yeah so I don't know I don't know
either but anyways I ultimately I
thought it was cute I'm so happy for the
parents who got that hour for themselves
um and you know people they're trying
Michael Buble showed up and like and
ruined it ruined it I need a break from
him a major break okay are you ready for
our next story um yeah you don't really
look ready honestly well I just put on
lipstick I like to the toast at my
vanity and I can't like be in front of
my makeup and just like not futz with it
you know what I mean yeah I'm doing it
from my vanity also but I haven't had
that temptation to futz with myself yet
well I'm like hating the lipstick but I
don't have any wipes here so I think I
have to keep it I think it looks nice it
just left me here to wear lipstick which
you don't put lipstick on a pig you know
it's like weird to put lipstick on a
face with no makeup yeah are you wearing
no makeup I was wondering what your
makeup routine is for Zoom nothing it
looks good so I'm like getting less and
less by the day so today I'm just
foundation mascara eyebrows concealer
lip soon concealers gonna go eyebrows
and mascara and foundation will always
stay unless I'm just gonna at a certain
point I'm going bare fetched because
like wow I don't even want to put on
makeup anymore like I want my skin to
heal it's like that um it's like that
mean like we are the virus like what
what could my skin do if I stop
tinkering with it every day yeah it's
like everyone in quarantine has been
able to like get their hair in a better
place their skin in a better place and
we're missing out so I'm now fully
diving like I'm not putting on makeup
until probably June yes
especially hair like I'm already done
with my heat tools you know I should put
them somewhere so they take up a lot of
space my bathroom like I can just set
them aside because I have another month
without them yep
I just I just I just okay princess
Beatrice has canceled her wedding amid
corona virus pandemic Princess Beatrice
and fiancé Eduardo m'appelle II motsi
woo like masa have officially called off
their wedding in light of the corona
virus pandemic the couple who were set
to Wed at st. James Palace in London on
May 29th with a reception hosted by
queen elizabeth ii to follow at
buckingham palace confirm the news on
thursday there are no plans to switch
venues or hold a bigger wedding they
aren't even thinking about their wedding
at this time a spokesperson for the
couple told people there will come and
come a time to rearrange but that's not
yet yeah that that sucks that sucks but
you know what like she's a princess like
at least she's not like losing you know
out financially like that doesn't the
taxpayer pay for it like I worry about a
real girl who lost her wedding you know
like great a pretty awesome there are so
many you know what I would do if if my
wedding were canceled like in and around
this time was looking about it because
because so many people like when we were
talking with Aaron Foster thing they
were like what would you do if you
couldn't have your wedding and so I
thought about it and I would pick a
weekend and I would say everyone we were
going to Las Vegas and we are getting
married because I wouldn't want to spend
that money again the money that I lost
like I just couldn't I couldn't part
with it twice so I would say we're going
to Las Vegas this weekend I would fight
anyone from the wedding who I was gonna
invite and we are getting married in a
chapel yeah I would definitely get
legally married around the same time
that I was supposed to get married
regular just because like of course a
weddings like about the party but at the
end of the day it's about the actual act
of getting married and I wouldn't want
to delay that I could wait for a party
but no I wouldn't want to wait to like
start my life with someone so I would I
don't even know if you can go to City
Hall but like I would go to City Hall I
would get married legally and then
figure it out later like parties can
wait but like marriages cannot yeah I
agree with that I just like couldn't go
it's like if my wedding was canceled
just a few weeks before it was supposed
to happen it means I've gone through all
of the stress of planning a wedding and
I just
I wouldn't be able to do that again not
even for a party later on like it just
for me personally and for people who can
do it like there's just stronger than I
am but I wouldn't be able to I would say
okay not meant to be we are going to Las
Vegas which we should be going there
anyway you know and you know what maybe
this quarantine has helped a lot of
brides realize that they're like
marrying the wrong man you know oh my
god I wonder if like they're taking it
as a sign mm-hmm definitely oh my god if
we have any corona brides out there let
us know right into dere toasters next
week totally okay next story
um Brett Eldredge has poured his life
changes into a brand new single quote
this is the best I've ever felt Brett
Eldredge release new music today after
years of just being m.i.a and the
smaller gap Gabrielle co-written by the
artist reflects the rewards and
realizations of his lengthy
self-improvement journey
quote I wasn't going to come back into
the public eye until I thought I had
something very important to say and it's
going to mean something it's been three
long years since Brett Eldredge has
recorded new music but don't think one
of country's most soulful crooners had
to shake off any cobwebs and when he
finally returned to the studio quote I
stepped into that booth and the first
song we nailed it one past the 34 year
old hitmaker tells people exclusively
quote it was the most excited I think I
felt in a long time happy for him this
is happy feather so crazy like who just
goes out and like goes m.i.a at the
height of their career like before this
he had released such a stellar album
like it's one of those albums you could
listen to five years from now ten years
from now and it's still just like
beautiful and he is so talented vocally
like such a weird thing for him to just
like take a step back I feel like that's
probably a smart thing to do I'm so
excited I didn't even know he was really
singing music today I knew that it was
coming I just didn't know when I have
missed him so much I have the biggest
crush on him and I'm really excited
about this so he release actually four
songs today I started to listen to
Gabrielle which is the main song um
before we were recording this but it's
just like too emotional and I just
wanted to set it aside for when I hit
that quarantine vibe later you know did
you add it to the playlist Oh it'll be
add to place but first times you listen
to it info just to make sure speaking of
incredible new
though Kelly Clarkson came out with a
song yesterday that was just everything
of this morning she came out with the
song in like multiple languages it's her
new project it's called I dare you and
if you hadn't heard the song yet like
you're missing out if you haven't heard
the song yet I dare you I dare you to
listen it's so good
anyways Brett Eldredge has previously
described many of the substantial life
changes he's made in his quest for
self-discovery taking up meditation and
journaling undergoing therapy
reconnecting to the outdoors and perhaps
most shockingly in the stage in day and
age giving up social media and going to
a flip phone
oh hi wish I had a flip phone I just had
a flip then I just wish I had a flip
phone so I got like [ __ ] slam it when
someone like it's Cuomo calling me
another two weeks in quarantine flip a
green completely agreed um anyway this
is awesome yes I'm happy for him truly
know that I am happy for us that we're
getting new music I'm happy for him that
he took the time to like make himself
better at the height of his career I'm
sure that's a really difficult thing to
do and now we're getting new music in
quarantine which is just like such a
gift in this time I am so appreciative
of artists who are still releasing music
during quarantine because so much has
stopped for people and music is one of
those things like at the beginning of
quarantine I wasn't listening to a lot
of music I was watching a lot of TV now
I just I cannot get the energy to put my
TV on like it almost makes me sad I
don't know why so I turn it on at night
when we have stuff to watch for the
toast but like during the day I'm really
listening just to the Hornstein's
playlist like all over the house so I'm
really grateful for people who are still
really seeing me music like I really
really appreciate it yeah well you know
what that's an amazing segue into our
next story because ryan tedder has a hot
take that I actually don't think you're
gonna agree with is it the story about
Ryan Tedder that's brought to you by
daily burn Oh obviously okay because all
the gyms are closed but you want to stay
active and get fit sign up for daily
burn at daily burn come and get give at
home workout to try for 30 days for free
if you want motivation daily burns
professional trainers have plenty to
spare and if you hate training alone you
can join a group session every weekday
there's programs that fits your needs
and fitness levels you can get 30 day
free trial if you sign up at daily
now jaylee burn calm as mentioned
previously Jackie and I have both
cracked a long time ago and working out
in your house is actually a lot easier
in my opinion than working out at a gym
like you don't have to see other people
and like you could just go straight to
the shower mm-hmm it's a daily burn and
who would have thought but it is amazing
it's everything of the sort so get fit
have fun
repeat with daily burn and daily burn
calm / toast so if you want to be
eligible for that 30-day free trial you
have to go to daily burn dot-com / toast
that's Dai ly bu r n dot-com / toast
check it out and you know get off the
couch for just like 30 minutes you know
what's funny is we even in quarantine
for so long that I feel like even like
though I've started working out from
home like I'm now ready for like new
workouts you know so daily burn has been
wonderful that's great okay are you
ready to hear this news about Ryan
Tedder that I don't think you're gonna
agree with I love Ryan Tedder so much
like I'm definitely up there as some of
his bug top fans so I'm ready one
republic's Ryan Tedder says he feels
it's quote tone-deaf to release new
music during the pandemic yeah what One
Republic frontman Ryan Tedder says he
feels it's toned up to release new music
during the corona virus pandemic the
musician 40 that's interesting explained
in an interview with USA Today not that
I see age or anything but if I did I
would say I thought he was younger then
oh I don't see age but when age shows
itself to me it's shocking yeah he said
in an interview with USA Today that his
band recently released a charity song
better days about this time and space
were in but only on the condition that
the profits be donated to the Red Cross
quote I feel weird stay and come buy my
stuff check me out he said meanwhile
people are sick and dying it's very tone
s he added that it's also quote really
hard to get anyone to pay attention to
new music right now and noted that one
recalled OneRepublic's latest album has
been delayed indefinitely until fall
I mean okay I don't think it's tone-deaf
to release music at all I think music is
very healing for some people but I do
think it's hard to get people to pay
attention to new albums and I think
trying to get people to pay attention to
new albums is tone deaf yes I don't like
a one republic fan it just seems like
anything that they want to do this like
just keeps getting delayed and so like
that's what I took from this article as
being the most upsetting but what I also
took from this article and just like
people in general is like here's the
thing let's stop making general
statements like if you want to release
music that's on you like just to blanket
it as tone-deaf like I can't deal with
people being so pressed about what other
people are doing like I just spent so
much time on Twitter yesterday and it
really got me thinking like how how many
losers exist in this world and it's
really sad because a lot of them have
Twitter accounts and so many of them get
so bent out of shape like genuinely like
their insides get turned up just because
of what someone else is doing like I
just don't know why like everyone can't
do what they want and like people could
just shut the [ __ ] up about it like it
just it drives me insane yeah well I
mean now I'm reading more about this
interview and like now I'm feeling RDH
about this song that isn't coming out he
said nobody can compete with the news
cycle right now and if you're not doing
that you're competing with Tiger king we
have this huge record that we wanted to
drop in mid May that we now won't it's a
summer song it's like the Beach Boys it
feels like it's such a hit but I'm not
going to do it in the middle of a
pandemic oh my god please drop it in
June please we feel it dangling it in
front of us and then snapping it away
the thing is though I'm not really
interested in a summer pop right now and
I wouldn't listen to that because it
wouldn't make me sad it's like how we
said about the Lady Gaga album like I
don't want to listen to that in this sad
time and then associate this like
amazing an semuc album with this sad
time in my life but I but like by June I
feel like I'm gonna need something like
please tell me I'm gonna need a song
that's gonna make me want to get it on
my house and that's why I was song
landlady eh I really wanted them to
choose that long way home song cuz
that's the song I want to listen to
right now cuz I made my feelings and
that champagne night song like what
champagne night what it what - champagne
they didn't know that at the time so I'm
sure that
I'm in comedy they would have chosen the
other song I'm not faulting them but
maybe if there wasn't a pandemic I'd be
sitting on my couch saying champagne
nights choose champagne nights but I
wanted the other one because that's what
I'm feeling right now
totally totally okay well our fifth and
final story is also a little music news
this is just the one about music because
music is one of the few small Joy's that
we have in this quarantine
what are your small joys in quarantine
what are the things that like just put
like a little bit of serotonin into your
brain white claw which I haven't been
able to drink literally since last week
because I got so violently hungover but
I think tonight I'm ready I'm ready to
come back
white claw any sort of games like me and
I've been doing a lot of puzzles like
anything that stimulates the brain
outside of my cell phone is really
stimulating and then another small joy
has been just like you know eating
whatever I want my toaster oven has been
like a true joy like I could make Bagel
Bites I can make cookies I made cookie
dough in a matter was [ __ ] delicious
last night my toaster oven has been a
real joy and Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills ooh that's a good one
what have yours mine are music the
quarren scenes playlist like such
fabulous news my peloton might add home
workouts we actually are setting up like
a little gym space and that member like
when I take you guys on my home tour we
didn't know what to do with the second
bedroom because we thought like the
quarantine would be one week lol now we
have like mass and weight and like we're
doing all of our fitness programs in
front of the TV it's something um Kindle
obviously and like the redheads book
club just like really been there for me
um probably cooking as well just like
being able to eat what I want and make
it for myself and heating pad like
that's my best friend I feel that 100
mens my best friend that's my best
friend
okay this and final story our boy is
just doin the best Luke Combs just wrote
the song that says what we're all
feeling fixed feet apart looks forward
to at the time when we can return to the
way of life that makes us human
Luke opens to debuted a new song during
his weekly livestream performances it
directly addresses the ongoing
coronavirus crisis and the social
distancing approach to daily life
it's called six feet apart it sums up
everything we're all feeling thinking
and dreaming about right now written by
combs Brent Cobb and Rob Schneider the
lyrics lay out the simple displays of
humanity that may have been taken for
may have been taken for granted just a
few weeks ago visiting with family
embracing a friend going to a bar quote
I miss my mom I miss my dad miss the
road I miss my band giving hugs and
shaking hands he sings about going on to
fantasize about the first things he'll
do once we're free together again his
song is like our podcast in a song like
what are we gonna do what do we miss
what I'm gonna do what are we looking
forward to what are we enjoying he said
oh they'll be shows some day when we are
singing yeah it's a mystery I suppose
just how long this thing goes I think
that's a direct quote from dr. Burks but
they'll be light after dark someday when
we aren't six feet apart if you haven't
watched his video I think it's on his
YouTube I watched it on his IG TV um it
just says everything that we're all
feeling right now he wrote it in like
one minute like the you know queen that
he is is fabulous like to be honest
songs like that song really makes me cry
for like a million reasons I don't know
why and it's so good and I just I don't
know how he could but like he has to
release it on Spotify like I need a real
version of it even though the live
version from his Instagram live that's
on YouTube now it's good I could just
really use like a studio and it's it's
kind of how Lady Antebellum is really
putting together those videos separately
with the music and the vocals and they
feel like in quarantine you could get a
song release like all these big rich
country stars they have studios in their
houses like they could do it yeah I
wonder if he has a studio in his house
if so he could do it and I agree mostly
because I just want it in my corn scenes
playlist I own Spotify and um I can't do
that from a Nike TV video I also caught
Ben my husband I'm listening to it
yesterday like literally on the couch
he's like did you hear about Lou Combs's
song I'm like excuse me wait that's
literally so crazy because my
husband came in here yesterday and said
do you listen to Luke combs a song and
actually had it yet and I was like no
and he's like it's called six feet apart
it's really good and I was like oh okay
thanks that's crazy it was really like
if you know us you know that that's
crazy that's great he doesn't even have
time to spend on his phone during the
day while he works and all I do is live
my life on my phone and like he's
telling me about hot new country music
you're telling me about how new country
music it was so crazy um should we dive
into our TV recaps Eggman that I believe
is being brought to you by article
please as the weather heats up and the
days get longer article is here to make
your dreams your dream patio a reality
with weather-resistant dining sets
loungers and sofas article selection of
outdoor furniture makes it easy to
create your patio ASIS just in time for
summer season and if you are someone who
is lucky enough to have outdoor space
whether it's a balcony a terrace a
rooftop a backyard a patio
you best be furnishing it to the nines
because you're spending a lot of time
there this summer an article has
everything that you need they combined
the curation of boutique furniture
stores with the comfort and simplicity
of shopping online articles team of
designers focus on beautifully crafted
pieces quality materials and durable
construction they are dedicated to a
modern aesthetic of mid-century
Scandinavian industrial and bohemian
designs fair prices they have up to 30%
over traditional retail prices you could
save up to 30% over traditional retail
prices they're about they're able to
keep their prices low by cutting out the
middleman and selling directly to you
know showrooms no sales people no retail
markups I have a lot of their indoor
furniture it's absolutely stunning and I
was just video time uh facetiming with
Lauren Elizabeth and she like redid so
many parts of her house like a lot of it
was from article and it looks so cute
they also have fast affordable shipping
it's available across the USA and Canada
and it's free on orders over nine
hundred ninety nine dollars all their in
stock items are delivered in two weeks
or less the best part of shopping with
article was that the shipping was crazy
like I play sea otter I forgot about it
and then this man called me he was like
hey we're coming today and I'm like you
are it was fabulous I wanted to kiss him
on the mouth article is offering our
listener if you dollars off your first
purchase of $100 or more go to article
comm slash coast and the discount will
automatically be applied at checkout so
you have to go to article com
toast to get $50 off your first purchase
of $100 or more
thank you article for sponsoring a real
hustlers in New York recap sign-on get
beautiful outdoor furniture for those of
us who can I thought that this episode
of real houses of New York was
fascinating because as someone who lives
in New York I have heard for years and
the understanding has generally been
that Ramona really runs in this like
snobby crowd and the housewives are
considered her like trashy friends and
when Dorinda came to the group she was
one of like Ramona's fancy her friends
and it was like a crazy like mixing of
the two so I feel like last night we got
a real insight into the social life of
Ramona Singer and I thought it was
fascinating and I was it was so
pertinent because in the news like for
the past like two weeks this house Joe
Farrell's house that the sand castle has
been all over paid chicks that it was
going for like the highest rental in
history in the Hamptons and some family
just rented it it was all in page six
it's like they didn't say who it was but
like this hedge fund guy and his family
rented that house for the summer for two
million dollars which just for the
summer is the highest rental in Hamptons
history Wow
so did the rents start already like are
they there for the quarantine so the
article said that the guy wanted to get
out with his family for quarantine so
they started now oh my god what a dream
like just to get to like that house that
has every activity you could possibly
think of and like you have it for the
summer and you have it for the queue
like oh my god take me with you I need
to meet these people I want to toast us
and daughters yeah if you're if your dad
is the guy hook us up please help us
it's just all very meta you know it was
like the sand castle and it's like 30
million and it was all coming together
okay so he was definitely interesting in
terms of you know like the social
hierarchy of New York City's elite but
it was deeply cringe-worthy like seeing
these women and I guess a cynic like in
a social circle that they don't belong
in but to me like there's some like that
they're my you know top tier they're
celebrities they're on TV who are you
and you know and they also like they do
have money
not like these like I don't know just
they just were acting like they were
sewer rat if yeah I don't know it made
me really kind of uncomfortable and it's
like Sonja Morgan like her last name is
Morgan like it's not and even when
Tinsley sent her past you know like
Ramona you're pretending to live this
life that like Sonja actually lived so I
kind of understand my Sonya like Wenzhou
off the deep end because I'm sure this
was like when she was so drunk and - I'm
sure this like brings her back and she
just I'm sure she worked so hard to like
break free from that life and be her own
person that she's not who anyone tell
her she has to behave this way in this
sort of house it looks like the least
fun party I've ever seen the women were
dressed like so [ __ ] randomly like
they were each going to a different
event and that is a theme with the Real
Housewives of New York like they need
some sort of stylist not for individuals
but to tell them like this is the vibe
we're going for it like it's so messy
cuz like look at the Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills and I understand not
everyone is the realize of Beverly Hills
but the Real Housewives of New York are
fabulous even when Bethenny was on the
show like two seasons ago they were in
the Hamptons and Bethenny was like what
are we wearing we all look like we're
going to like some different and crazy
event I would actually say that the
best-dressed person the most
appropriately dressed person for the
occasion was Lea oh I totally disagree I
thought she was except for except for
the jean jacket and also and also these
women need to stop wearing crossbody
bags I'm sorry but you're not in college
going from frat party to bar to downtown
and you need to have your whole life in
your purse like get a small clutch come
on I don't think that anyone like I'm
brutal about crossbody bags I really am
but like I just don't think that adults
like should be wearing crossbar in
advance I agree a bag I don't agree with
it with the Lea outfit I think she was
like heavily underdressed that's
something like you would wear to surf
Lodge I really thought Tinsley looked
good she was slightly overdressed to be
honest the only person who really whose
outfit was appropriate for like the
boring old crowd was Dorinda with her
pantsu like she feel good yeah and I
think it was Pucci I agree like Ramona
was not dressed appropriately Ramona was
on a revolve trip in Jamaica a hundred
percent and she's telling everyone else
what to wear like
it was really wait I have a question the
literally how can we have this
conversation without talking about the
atrocity that was Luann's outfit oh my
god justice if you leave the shoes but
it's so weird because I feel like LuAnn
always does look right she lives in the
Hamptons pretty much like how did she
miss a memo on what to wear to this big
party they just look like a hodgepodge
disaster I also feel like Ramona did not
give the group like real um and a good
idea of what they were going to like
they didn't know this person like
Tinsley had gone on the date with him so
it was like a group of people they had
never met Ramona made it seem like if
she was hosting a party but she wasn't
she was invited to a party and brought
all of her friends it was like the worst
looking party of all time I can't
believe that they had to suffer through
that like not only did the party not
look fun like I agree going on the tour
of someone's house like unless we're
friends like I don't want to take my
clunky ass heels walk down and up your
stairs and like play bowling with in my
dress I just don't want to do that and I
agree with Duren that it is so tacky
especially in like such a big house to
like ask for a tour I agree but I just I
think there's a special place in hell
for Americans who label things as so
American like okay we get it you lived
abroad [ __ ] but you're [ __ ] American
retweet retweet retweet like touring a
house can be tacky without it being so
American like why do you have to bring
more countries do this yeah no it's just
like in these like in these tough times
and in the current climate like we're
already a nation divided like what are
you doing but she was right like all
these women like running around Joe
Farrelly it's so mortifying like they've
never been in a nice house before it was
shocking like these it was it was truly
it was so uncomfortable I act like so
rude and awed by just a little bit of
money like I thought you all guys come
for money right and that's why the
episode was particularly depressing
because one it really wasn't very um you
were looking in the mirror and like you
couldn't deny the fact that like this
franchise has fallen far like these
women like the women at the party like
those are the real housewives like not
trash bags rolling in like with their
camera crew and it was also a really sad
episode because I don't think I've
really ever watched a housewives
gathering at a party that wasn't theirs
like they were very much guests and they
were very much like a spectacle and like
everyone was looking around and it was
just really sad to watch it was so sad
Sonia was legit off her rocker
I was crying she put her belly up to
that man's belly he said yes belly to
belly who are we okay it was me die like
when she was at the winery and they were
all sharing like what makes him
vulnerable and like she I love him Bravo
does those montages of people just like
talking talking she I got one foot in
the nursery we're gonna be big babies
she was being so funny like yes I just
wish she could have stayed like in that
level of drug for the whole day but
things spiraled obviously and I think
when everyone went home and napped she
continued to drink which was obviously a
mistake because she was and it's like I
was feeling so conflicted it's like
Ramona is like so obnoxious she's like
the worst type of friend like you would
never want her as a friend she's always
looking over your shoulder see who's
behind you who's better to hang out with
but at the same time like she was being
like embarrassed of her friends but her
friends were being embarrassing they
were being so embarrassing mostly just
Sonya honestly I thought Tinsley and Lea
handled themselves correctly but also
you don't go day-drinking and then like
somebody's behavior was perfect for like
a trip in Miami but you don't take her
friends she will winery and then
continue to drink at home and then bring
them to this party where they have to
act like they're in a penguin suit ya
know it was it's almost like I'm gonna
set them up because like she left the
winery early she went to the date like
she was obviously composed to the whole
day yeah and then the woman who came up
to Sonja and called her a trophy wife
Elise that was like really crazy and
then Sonia called tinsy turkey wife and
then tinsy was like I met my husband in
high school like you married our one
hundred year old and then Sonya was like
I don't shave my [ __ ] and that was the
end he was like I'm not a trophy like I
don't shave my [ __ ] that was so crazy
but honestly next week
looks even crazier because alia gets
turned oh yeah and like they totally
trashed him on his house with a vibrator
and the chicken and the broken champagne
bottle in the pool oh my god I was
laughing so hard when I saw the preview
I'm really excited and I'm like looking
forward to them trashing Ramona's house
a little bit like don't throw a party
and have girls drinking like even a girl
whoo but it's like when she's not
drinking she's boring and then when
she's drinking it's like oh there's a
dildo in my chicken yeah it's too much
she took you guys she legit tried to
tell you guys Lulu and saga it's very
strange to me hum Ramona's really kowtow
to Luann's demands and it reminds me how
last week they had that very strange
dinner like there's some sort of weird
arrangement between Ramona and LuAnn
that they're like not gonna fight um
because they both rely so much on this
show and like they can't they can't not
be on this show so I normally Ramona
would have never apologized what Luann's
text was [ __ ] insane yeah and by the
way one spider does not mean it's
raining spiders and talking about
someone's house like that is actually so
weird like coming up after you're
staying and even if you don't like it
coming up to breakfast being like Ramona
you've got a heating problem Ramona
you've got a spider problem like it's
just so rude and to be honest I agree
LuAnn shouldn't have been in Ramona's
house she lives in the Hamptons like she
could have spent the night she doesn't
even drink she could have went home to
her house but she made the decision to
come and stay and she kept going and
coming and going and leaving like stay
or don't stay yeah also um last week we
were wondering why LuAnn just didn't
stay in their room that Tinsley was in
and then Tinsley and Lea could have
shared that twin bedroom but Ramona did
say that LuAnn didn't want to share a
bathroom with someone that she didn't
know so she chose to be downstairs and
the more I think about it the more I
know for certain that Ramona gave during
to the bathroom because she wants the
best room in the Berkshires and like I
did that's total of course and that's
the only reason why Ramona even invited
the women to stay at her house she's
never had all the women stay or how she
sometimes has Sonja but she's never had
all the women and she did it just so she
had a good room and great barrington
yeah honestly I'm glad they're all
saying their it looks really fun I can't
believe next week they're still there
like I thought the trip was over this
a perfect trip next week like it's
spring break at Ramona's house I know it
looks so fun and I also love the little
tidbits of information that Ramona's
house is valued at eight point five
million dollars yeah it's a really nice
house that's why I don't understand when
they go to a house it's okay nicer but
like it sits in the same sphere ya know
it said a million dollar house it's on
the water like it she just renovated it
which I think really she did too like up
the appraisal because she added a ton of
value it actually looks good like even
though it's not everyone's taste it's
clean and renovated and that's all
people look for in the Hamptons so oh
also um I actually found Ramona's house
on a summer rental website I was like
that house looks for Millie er I mean I
think that'd be like really should stay
there I think we should rent it for the
whole summer
I would absolutely love to um anything
else about house size before we jump
into Kardashians nope that's it for me
okay so we're gonna jump into our our
Keeping Up with the Kardashians recap
which is brought to you by fiber finding
freelance talent for your business or
project sometimes you need to pivot
quickly to meet a goal or maybe an
unexpected obstacle occurs making it
impossible to meet your deadline with
the size of your current team so where
do you go to find on-demand talent how
much will it cost it can how can you be
certain that they'll deliver finding the
right freelancer can be time-consuming
frustrating and expensive but fivers
platform helps keeps businesses moving
with a network of trusted freelance
talent and it's a bustling business we
are always looking for graphic designers
video editors audio editors and fibers
been super helpful in helping us find
people and be knowing how much we're
supposed to pay so we don't are not
getting like swindled on Craigslist
whether you're launching your first
business scaling your current business
or in need of extra support to complete
a project fiber is here to help you
evolve adapt and grow fiber connects
businesses with freelancers who offer
hundreds of digital services including
graphic design copywriting web
programming film editing and more you
can find what you're looking for
instantly searching by service deadline
price reviews and more you know exactly
what you're paying for upfront because
there's no negotiation needed plus they
have 24/7 customer service that you can
count on their sellers have worked with
some of the most influential brands in
the world
checkout fiverr.com today and receive
10% off your first order by using our
code toast
that's FIV ER our code is coast
find all the digital services you need
place at fiverr.com slash toast again
that's fiber FIV ER our comm code toast
love it okay keeping up keeping up it
was another mundane episode but to me
the difference in this week's and last
week's episode was huge like I didn't
feel like this week we were being
swindled hoodwinked and bamboozled into
thinking some of this [ __ ] was real I
thought this episode was like so sweet
Kim has not been in the last two
episodes really at all which I find
interesting like maybe she was just busy
at that point in time but as someone who
like really carries the show it's it's
weird to see her not be there yeah but I
think everyone else really pulled their
weight and I think Kylie totally stepped
up
yeah I'm even though like her scenes
with Stas were obviously scripted
because like she doesn't film all the
time so they wouldn't catch that candid
conversation where she just like
realizes she needs to get her eyes done
I didn't care I absolutely loved seeing
Stas like I think she is really a great
foil for Kylie on television as a
character and I would love more they're
just like so glam I love how they're
always twinning like are they having
sleepovers that's so fun yet - Stas live
in Kylie's house now that there's an
extra bedroom since Jordan moved it out
no according to sauces Instagram like
she's a place of her own like she does
her own thing very much so but like they
have sleepovers I think after they go to
the movies with their friends like how
fun is that ya know like their life
seems so fun and honestly the LASIK eye
surgery was for Ricki me the [ __ ] out
like it's literally so creepy to like
touch your eye but it was actually very
cool a new editing thing that they're
doing is splicing in like old home
videos and old episodes of the
Kardashians with the new stuff like when
it's appropriate like Chloe with jumping
in the pool as a kid and then Chloe
sitting out by her pool I like that a
lot it's almost like they have so little
content because nobody wants to film
that they're now relying on home videos
and old episodes no but I don't mind it
and it's crazy that we did see Kim get
LASIK like ten years ago and now Kylie's
going through the same thing um when
Kylie and Stas were like Chirag dup
sitting at the doctor's office with
their eyes closed just smiling I was
laughing so hard they were just like
yeah there are some puppies they really
look alike yeah I mean I'm sure they
just like go to the same doctor yeah it
was fabulous I just love seeing Kylie's
house like we don't see a
enough of it and what I find really
interesting is that Kylie's house that
she lives in it's like not as it's not
what you would think for a billionaire
but at the end of the day it's just like
her and her baby like how much house do
you need but like most billionaires
would have like literally a hundred
thousand square-foot house just because
they can but she is just as nice of a
house as I Khloe and Kourtney like but
she's obviously a lotta tree I think
that's cool I think the same thing when
you're in her four year like it's not
like she's at Jeffery stars house like
she lives in a very nice house I think
Khloe's house is bigger I think
Courtney's house might even be bigger
Courtney has more kids obviously but
Kylie like doesn't live so crazily
compared to what we know she can afford
yeah and it's like when she moved out of
the house at 18 Chris gave her that like
regular house like it was Kylie bought
it but it was like a regular starter
house like the house is that Kourtney
and Kim used to live in then when she
started making a lot of money on Kylie
cosmetics she moved into this house
which was like the same level as her
sisters but she has been in the house
for a few years and her finances have
far exceeded her sisters and she hasn't
moved out which i think is really cool I
think it's cool to like even when she
does her YouTube videos of like cooking
with stormy or her help her
um Christmas decorations like she has
you know an entrance and stairs in a
living room in the kitchen like it's
just it's cute she's on she's an
elevator and right like all this crazy
[ __ ] it's just a really really really
nice home I agree um what else oh the
stuff with Kris Jenner in the photos
like I thought that was so funny
hysterical and I loved it like they
really tried like when the production
person said the thing about Khloe's
nails it's like ya know that would have
been a dead giveaway like they really
were trying to drive it home I thought
Tracy did a great job it was just it was
really funny to see and I love that
they're going for a long-term prank like
they're not just looking to be like
gotcha like we didn't even see the
photos yet like I like that this is
they're trying to emulate like the Todd
kraines magic that lasted over an entire
season and I'm excited because I love a
good prank a harmless prank me too and I
also I've loved the art vandal a prank
like I thought it was genius and
hilarious and that also lasted a long
time so I'm here for Khloe and Scott
like cooking up some mischievousness
yeah it was cute um I also just really
love Kris Jenner and I feel like
watching Kardashians especially when
she's always like momager whatever when
she's like really being mom she's like
so funny like I just loved watching her
take care of Kylie it's obviously I when
she was pulling when she was pulling the
taco out of her mouth I was getting
really annoyed no but like that was
funny and cute like that's a Kris Jenner
I love and I feel like Kylie's
definitely her favorite but Kylie really
like loves to hang out with her friends
and Kris was just like loving like being
needed by Kylie because she like never
really is and I just left yes but I just
love seeing her as like a mom do you
don't I mean yes I agree with that like
she just is like cooking up tacos like
how do you not have the salt um but I
really was just getting really annoyed
for some personal reason of when she was
pulling them out of Ramallah think it
was just ah burning there's a special
place in hell for people who take food
away from other people yeah and just
like tease them with food four times
yeah
Oh Malika told Khloe that she was
pregnant and quite possibly the
strangest way ever completely agreed
that was the Atlanta thing like so weird
no it was so weird like I still don't
get it are they moving to Atlanta no and
it's like no offense to them but Khloe
like what kind of work could you guys be
doing in Atlanta like what do they do
like I maybe if they were filming
something maybe they maybe they act or
maybe like Malika would be doing another
reality show like relationship coach
what is it called love yeah yeah famous
X loves famous love famously single
single
yeah no I just thought like for someone
who's been Khloe's like best best best
friend the whole announcement lacked
like any real joy and it was like such a
weird way to say it like it was kind of
cringe II it was very cringy I totally
agree and then I guess the final
storyline is Tristan and Chloe
co-parenting very cute I hope that the
sperm donor about she references in the
next episode is Tristan and I'm here it
I I found that whole saga to be like a
little sad like I get what Chloe man
it's like I have never had to co-parent
but like it's like it's Chloe's baby you
know and true the Tristan scenes make me
so uncomfortable because
like he's so trying so hard and he's
like so lame and cringy like with the
stuff that he says in the to your bags
and stuff but at the same time like this
is the guy that kissed Jordan and like
how are we supposed to like separate I
don't know also what was so interesting
was when Tristan was Chyna I get Chloe
to stay and he was like coco takes
Cleveland and she was like that could
have been a great solution if you were
open to that sort of thing so it's clear
that when she was in Cleveland like he
was not down to film anything making her
life even more difficult the my my my
how the tables have turned and I'm just
loving watching her make him eat [ __ ]
like time and time again like she will
not let him back in like he is just
doing everything and she is humbling him
and I'm loving that yeah me too
it was a good episode it was a good
episode it was it was very good um
Thursday night sure great night for
television I'm so glad that it's Friday
I need to embark on my weekend I just
have like so many crazy plans and it's
only wild we hope that everyone has a
great weekend stay safe try and stay
simulated thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found so that Spotify iTunes
stitcher Public Radio I already know
cashbox all the places whoever you
listen to podcast find us the morning
toast and leave a five star review how
about a beautiful stunning and smart we
are have a great weekend guys have a
great weekend everyone head over to
patreon.com slash the morning toast for
more content including my quarantine day
in the life video and then we have three
more episodes after that coming at you
this month also make sure to check out
the redheads if you're looking for
something to do this weekend read the
latest redheads book and listen to the
episode because I worked really hard on
the audio and it's really fun and I
think you'll really like my friends with
that said have a great weekend bye